what are you doing here these two
knuckleheads were fighting each other
what could have been worse
i was not ready to face dirkus today
so what happened well apparently there
was some name-calling and shoving on the
playground by the time a teacher
separated them luke was sitting on
manny's chest luke that's not like you
wait a minute you're luke's father
grandfather so manny's father is
javier can i see guy
that's where he gets his fire okay
you're he's our son and my grandson i'm
his daughter
so you're his uncle
stop saying that or sit on your chest
again oh wait a second is that what this
was all about he keeps calling me his
nephew you are my nephew shut up okay
okay
i'm getting the sense that you're all
related uh
somehow uh so it's probably best if you
work this out at home so the boys can go
back to class okay
but we're not happy about this boys this
is not how mature young men behave
here's your note from his past water hmm
look i wouldn't worry they're good kids
it's just tough when one kid's a little
different yes
you heard how she said that right
jace
she thought luke was the weird one
luke her kid gets his head stuck in the
furniture and manny is the different one
i will tell you what's weird our sun is
not weird what's weird is that her kid
wears aftershave dresses like a count i
think we should cancel with them for the
barbecue if we cancel it'll just make
this a bigger deal than it is it'd be
good for luke and manny to spend some
time
might be good for you and gloria too why
she's always had a problem with me
i think i'm gonna find out what it is
that's the worst thing you could do just
sweep it under the rug
i'm not a sweeper trust me on this i
think you two need to talk it out
i don't have anything to say to her
she's the one with the problem not me
whose side are you on she's my daughter
you're my wife
let's remember what's important here
there's a football game mom
i just hate it when my two girls aren't
getting along
exactly is she your girl
so i brought dessert
okay thank you
i make tai too
you can never have too many pies right
okay whoa whoa everybody take a deep
breath let's think about getting real
phil no why phil no
what is phil doing i'm just gonna say it
there's tension between you two bam it's
out there i'm gonna kill you
i think he's right
and i think we should talk about it
that's what i'm talking about
you two talking
about it
okay the truth
i sometimes feel like you don't like me
wow
powerful powerful stuff
claire tell us how that makes you feel
right now i'm feeling a lot of anger no
don't tell me tell her
gloria right now i'm really angry at
phil let's respect the process
gloria i don't know why you think i
don't like you where sometimes when you
see me you make that face what face like
this
i do not make a phone oh my god that is
so clear mitchell see
she does that with everyone
it's just her face no it's not just the
face
from the beginning i feel like manny and
i are not welcome in this family that is
so crazy no it's not so crazy it's how i
feel
i am sorry
if you feel that way i really am because
from the moment i met you i have tried
to make you feel comfortable with us
you think it's all in my head no
kind i don't know i mean
we really love having you and manny in
our family really really
so
you don't have to be so defensive
i do that don't i mm-hmm
i'm feeling a hug
i was thinking
group hug but this is like
there if i could oh my god there's
hugging
[Music]
you